the new jack reacher sequel starring Tom
Cruise open this weekend and it beat the
first film's opening by almost eight
million dollars did very well I didn't
see it yet okay but I will say I love
how tough and cool Tom Cruise seems in
the film's trailer I really do take this
is the actual trail take a look at how
cool he is two things are going to
happen in the next 90 seconds first that
phone over there it's gonna ring second
you're gonna be wearing these cuffs on
your way to prison well that is one
magnificent prophecy yeah pretty cool
now that that's the official trailer
they released but apparently they shot a
couple of versions of that scene before
that would just trust me on this
[Applause]
it's plausible they shot a couple of
versions of that scene before they
settled on that particular one I got a
hold of one here's an example two things
are gonna happen in the next 90 seconds
excuse me first that cuckoo clock is
gonna go off second you'll switch a red
velvet cupcake in your hand well that is
one magnificent two things are gonna
happen in the next 90 seconds excuse me
first a cat and a green hat will walk
out of the kitchen second an egg will
fall out of your mouth eight things are
gonna happen second excuse me first that
fish on the wall is gonna sneeze
second I place any symbols third
stigmata on both your hands
fourth is this your card fit sandwich
I'm skating six-foot star on the tiny
Christmas tree seventh harmonic ate
another egg
[Music]
try
[Applause]
you